did you know Farmers have used crop
rotation for thousands of years this
practice dates back to ancient
civilizations where it was a crucial
part of their agricultural systems
ancient civilizations in Rome Greece and
China knew its value they understood
that rotating crops could prevent soil
depletion and improve yields they saw
how it made their crops healthier and
more plentiful by alternating the types
of crops grown they could maintain soil
fertility and reduce the risk of crop
failure this ancient practice is still
relevant today modern farmers and
gardeners continue to use crop rotation
to enhance soil health and productivity
it is a Cornerstone of sustainable and
productive gardening crop rotation helps
to balance the nutrients in the soil
making it a vital technique for
long-term agricultural
success crop rotation is a simple but
powerful technique it involves planning
and knowledge but the benefits far
outweigh the effort it involves growing
different crops in a planned sequence on
the same piece of land this sequence can
vary depending on the crops and the
specific needs of the soil imagine a
cycle where each crop benefits the next
like a well choreographed dance for
example legumes can fix nitrogen in the
soil benefiting the crops that follow
this dance of crops helps keep the soil
healthy by rotating crops farmers can
prevent the buildup of pathogens and
pests that often occur when one species
is continuously cropped it also helps to
manage pests and diseases different
crops are attract different pests so
rotating them can break the pest's life
cycle the beauty of crop rotation lies
in its Simplicity and Effectiveness it
doesn't require expensive equipment or
technology just a good understanding of
plant needs and soil Health by
understanding the basic principles even
novice gardeners can reap its rewards
it's a technique that can be scaled to
any size from small home gardens to
large agricultural Fields let's delve
deeper into the fascinating world of
crop rotation and discover how you can
implement it in your garden with a
little planning and knowledge you can
create a thriving sustainable garden
that benefits both you and the
environment crop rotation is like a
dance for your plants instead of
planting the same thing in the same
place each year you switch it up this
simple Act of changing the crops in a
particular area brings life back into
the soil imagine planting corn one year
then beans the next followed by squash
this this is a basic example of crop
rotation each crop has different needs
and uses different nutrients from the
soil by rotating crops you prevent the
depletion of essential nutrients
different crops also have different root
systems which grow to different depths
this variation in root depth improves
soil structure overall crop rotation is
a win-win for your
garden rotating your crops is like
giving your garden a vitamin boost it
comes with a variety of benefits one of
of the biggest is healthier soil
different crops use and replenish
nutrients in different ways this
prevents nutrient depletion and keeps
the soil fertile crop rotation also
helps control pests and diseases when
you plant the same crop in the same spot
pests specific to that crop can build up
in the soil rotating crops disrupts
their life cycle reducing pest pressure
and the best part healthier soil and
fewer pests lead to better harvests crop
rotation can improve your yield sign
ific L you'll be amazed at the
difference it makes in your
garden don't worry you don't need to be
an expert to start rotating your crops
it's easier than you think a simple
3-year rotation plan is perfect for
beginners Begin by dividing your garden
into three sections year one plant heavy
feeders like tomatoes corn or cabbage in
section one these crops need lots of
nutrients year two plant legumes like
beans or peas in section one legumes are
nitrogen fixers meaning they add
nitrogen back into the soil year three
plant root crops like carrots potatoes
or beets in section one these crops help
break up the soil repeat this cycle for
the other two sections and you're all
set section five planning your crop
rotation a step-by-step guide planning
your crop rotation is like putting
together a puzzle each piece has its
place and when they all fit together the
picture becomes clear start by listing
the crops you want to grow think about
your favorite vegetables herbs and even
flowers that can benefit your garden
ecosystem then group them into four
basic categories heavy feeders legumes
root crops and leafy greens this helps
in understanding their nutrient needs
and how they can complement each other
next draw a simple diagram of your
garden beds this visual aid will help
you plan more effectively and make
adjustments as needed divide the bed
into sections based on your rotation
plan for example three sections for a
3-year rotation this ensures that no
single type of crop depletes the soil
nutrients now assign each crop category
to a section on your diagram following
the rotation
principles this step is crucial for
maintaining soil health and reducing
pest issues don't forget to consider the
sunlight requirements of each crop when
placing them in your garden some plants
thrive in full sun While others prefer
partial shade with a little planning and
attention to detail you'll have a well
structured crop rotation plan ready to
go this thoughtful approach will lead to
a more productive and sustainable
garden section six Advanced crop
rotation tips for seasoned gardeners
once you've mastered the basics you can
take your crop rotation to the next
level consider incorporating cover crops
into your rotation cover crops like
Clover or Ry grass are planted in the
offseason they protect and nourish the
the soil another Advanced technique is
to rotate plant families not just
individual crops this helps to further
disrupt Pest and disease cycles that may
be specific to certain plant families
for instance instead of just rotating
Tomatoes rotate all members of the
nightshade family such as Peppers
eggplants and potatoes this adds an
extra layer of protection for your
[Music]
garden section seven the power of crop
families in rotation planning think of
plant families like extended families in
the Plant World they share similar
characteristics and unfortunately
vulnerabilities to pests and diseases
that's why rotating entire plant
families is key to long-term Garden
health for example the brasic family
which includes broccoli cauliflower and
kale are all susceptible to clubroot
disease planting them in the same spot
year after year increases the risk of
this disease taking hold by rotating
with families like legumes such as beans
and peas or cucurbits like cucumbers and
squash you disrupt the disease cycle and
protect your future crops remember
diversity is key in crop
rotation section eight companion
planting maximizing benefits within a
rotation companion planting is like
playing Matchmaker for your plants it
involves planting different crops
together that benefit each other for
example planting Basel alongside
Tomatoes can enhance tomato flavor and
deter pests you can integ great
companion planting within your crop
rotation plan for instance when it's
time to plant your legumes consider
companion planting them with carrots the
legumes will fix nitrogen benefiting the
carrots while the carrots will help
loosen the soil for better legume growth
this synergistic approach maximizes the
benefits of crop rotation and companion
planting creating a thriving and
productive Garden
ecosystem section nine troubleshooting
and adapting your crop rotation plan
even with the best laid plans things
don't always go smoothly in the garden
sometimes despite your best efforts
unexpected challenges arise you might
encounter unexpected pest outbreaks
diseases or changes in soil conditions
that can affect your crop's health and
yield don't worry crop rotation allows
for flexibility this means you can
adjust your planting strategy to better
suit the current conditions keep a close
eye on your garden and be prepared to
adapt your plan if needed
regular monitoring helps you catch
issues early and make necessary changes
if you notice a particular pest or
disease becoming a problem you may need
to adjust your rotation to include crops
that are resistant to that specific
issue this proactive approach can save
your garden from significant damage
remember gardening is a continuous
learning experience there is always
something new to learn whether it's from
books other gardeners or your own
observations don't be afraid to
experiment observe and make adjustments
ments to your crop rotation plan as you
gain more experience and knowledge about
your garden each season brings new
insights and being flexible will help
you become a more successful
Gardener section 10 the future of food
crop rotation for sustainable
agriculture crop rotation isn't just an
old-fashioned gardening technique it's a
crucial element of sustainable
agriculture as we Face the challenges of
climate change and resource depletion
it's more important than ever to adopt
practices that protect our environment
by improving soil Health reducing
Reliance on synthetic fertilizers and
pesticides and increasing biodiversity
crop rotation contributes to a more
resilient and sustainable food system
it's a simple yet powerful tool that can
help us grow healthier food for
generations to come by embracing crop
rotation we're not just tending to our
Gardens we're investing in the future of
food and the health of our
planet section 11 unearth the magic of
crop rotation a call to action crop
rotation is a gift from the past and a
solution for the future it's a simple
yet powerful technique that can
transform your garden and contribute to
a more sustainable world so why not give
it a try start by implementing a basic
rotation plan in your garden observe the
benefits firsthand as you gain
confidence experiment with Advanced
Techniques like cover cropping and
companion planting share your knowledge
with fellow guardi and spread the word
about the magic of crop rotation
together let's unearth the full
potential of crop rotation and create a
healthier and more abundant future for
all